why is there safe thing why  oh man I love working at Disney World  it's my favorite you guys need to take  some relaxation therapy classes get some  scented candles  take a nice herbal bath smoke some weed  I don't care do something relax  Parker lair does not condone the smoking  of any herbal substances that duck is  smart and apparently to the Internet  that duck is very sexy to some people I  know the Internet's a little messed up  place I've been here for a long time no  it's not you and I'll do me  we won't do each other probably I was a  good poem right there get my overtime  paycheck because for some reason outside  of the 20 bucks a week wasn't good  enough goddamn in for this six-figure  salary wouldn't be good enough for this  move don't move don't move don't move  don't move I didn't move as you all may  know and then I've been told many times  I need to go back to the 6th night oh  god I'm never gonna make it because it's  ok ok there is a prepare bird a bird is  the word